if you could choose between point Luna
and another Corporation and you get
Point Luna and have zero Earth Tracks in
hand would you do it I don't know I I
think I might be tempted because I like
to play Greedy but you guys
I think you guys you're so insanely
greedy
so here now is another question for you
guys
even though you can satisfy the Omni
would you ever pick that over teraxa
just because it's 20 more 20 less gold
but then you have the Omni effect
depends on that it really depends on the
hand but in general it's a no from me
yeah you will take character right
it's I don't know maybe like something
like 20 80 percent
where the hand is playable for on me
yeah
like this the flexibility of the extra
20 cash is just not to be underrated
it's almost a total gen of production
so you're telling me that I can actually
click on something right now and I can
see
yeah you should
no it's not working anymore no
yeah but if I recall this is the uh one
of all production and ten in one
production and then it's easy no it's
it's the other map it's the tax
diversifier for eight different tracks
Rim settler for three jovians uh
Energizer for six energy
tactician for five cards with
requirements yeah and polar Explorer
okay so eight different attacks that's
really annoying so you're telling me it
used to be that you could see it no you
can't
yep
frustrating
[Music]
I could also just
hmm
I have a few interesting choices here
I got robotic Workforce my Dome farming
or I could robotic Workforce mobile just
to get like a bunch of heat production
General good
yeah I can also get it on uh the other
options though
he's talking about the Mohawk Prelude
yeah for sure
I know because I have the area on hand
yeah also Dome farming could be
interesting
don't environment is generally a
stronger
yeah
I think I think Mojo area is better to
copy but the more will Prelude
yes and then I'd also picked home
farming as a club I think I'll go a bit
more after plan production
with the with this line
[Music]
but on the other hand it would be more
fun to play Omni wouldn't it
yeah if you equate fun with stupid
but I agree it would be more fun yeah
all right I mean of course you can
throw your head in a wall and then say
hey I'm in a very bad position so now if
I win it's way more of an accomplishment
yeah
we always buy the fourth card
would you buy this
we always buy the last card as well
always this fourth card always buy last
card always buy really this one I could
not not the one on this page okay well
this one no no
fourth card on this page yeah always buy
this the fifth the fifth card on the
second page and the fourth card and the
second page these are always buys
this
yeah
wow
all right
I mean this one is just because you guys
like terraforming so this I understand
this one should not get a better
I should get some some better energy
blocks than this one during the game
though
I mean I'll try it but I'm not I'm not
sold on this one
we still have our ranks on by the way
but I guess it is unranked right no
noise
it always shows rang down
and I think it always shows a highlight
draw even though it's standard draw
just another line of potato coat they
can't be bothered to fix let's see
oh I gained a precious five ah you
really did this yes
and I was like well he played the ocean
not on titanium I am fine
but I'm not fine oh this bothers me no
absolutely not fine
so which one is this is this uh
could it really be Iron mining
Industries nah I don't think you it's
probably the the one that cost 30 the
two titanium for 30. I'm guessing I mean
calculate how many cash I have right
yeah that's what I'm doing so I just
took seven plus seven so that's uh 35
but plus seven yes so that's not enough
mining industry but it could be enough
if if you steal the lake with titanium I
miss six cash
so then I would have had 20 minutes and
I would have been sad
is it solitaire
no it is a very big space card
and I am sad now and I played next gen
uh those are my best guesses so let's
say or the uh the two titanium
production for 30.
knowing you it's probably soleta I'm
guessing
[Music]
it's hella's though
like he almost always feels like this
the the strategy the real temp on our
strategy where you just finish with as
many as few cards as possible is really
bad on Hellas because it completely
locks you out of milestones
oh so this is the yeah yeah I see and so
you like on passes you just get those
cool Milestones or on Elysium you just
go up to 10 heat Broad and take it and
whatever but in here if you do try a
fast rush you just get nothing
like polar Explorer is the more
realistic Milestone if you want to go
for a fast Rush yeah
yeah I remember we talked about this in
the in the Disco so this is probably the
map I should play that because I'm I'm
greedy right yeah
makes sense
I think on average it's like 0.3 gems
slower this map
oh interesting
gotta love that
man I'm director I get in a quiet
company look at me getting so much cash
quad companies let's go
just what I wanted and it's weird that
your opener was so weak that you miss
that you ended with like 30 cash
yeah
so so maybe
my mission of production was not that
terrible
because your your Sabo was effectively
saboring for me for way more because I
missed the production of my car yes for
sure
yeah
okay I don't give you the second draft
track
so the big question is do I keep this
this cabbage will City
I think probably not but it is
tempting
but I don't think I should do it
I mean capital is just bad on this map
right
you have no spot where you can get uh
three oceans adjacent
yeah I am looking at the city sooner
sooner rather than later there but sure
but I mean get a good City
yeah capital is just
a bad SP City if you don't get a good
ocean adjacency and a good ocean
adjacency is too
then you are kind of maybe okay if you
have steel but you'd rather want three
and otherwise other cities are just
better
yeah
because usually those cities are also
not adjacent to Oceans because you have
the green Aries there yeah
I think in the in the north west you
know where I already put one water up
there this was where I could have placed
the capital to get two plants and to get
this SP some some water
I'm not sure probably still I mean you
can't play it because it has a Fortune
requirement and
it costs a crap ton of energy so it's a
really really expensive car yeah the
energy I have though
but yeah probably still not worth it I
mean you don't have the energy
this is this is what I meant when I
wrote it you pay an extra 14 cash to
play Capital this is expensive it's not
about having the energy it's about
paying the energy yeah yeah
you're right
um
so what do I play
let's just draw some cards
because why not
make sense
I think I will 100 of the game we played
I played death Center gen 2.
yeah nice
and has 100 win rate so it must be the
best card in the game
think about it interesting yeah think
about it
statistics statistics statistics yes
okay so you actually saw about me for
16 the first gen
uh it wasn't mining oh because you have
a dented workers
yep
disgusting
quite a nice sabotage
yeah
I'm still just floating so much gold I
don't know what to do with my girl now
okay I'm a little scared about my energy
but you don't have the tags to play the
second one
so it's fine
actually I do have a head here
I could actually just SP a Greenery
together no no ESPN to plants hi you USB
you mean SP Greenery on the bottom yes
and this is rather bad because then you
are forced to stay in the bottom yeah
and you want the rebates on top so if
you just SP an ocean you can then
convert next-gen because you start next
gen and then you just get the good
rebate spot on the top yeah you're right
it's probably better
it just feels very bad to just float
like 30 gold foreign
the one on the top right really
of course oh yeah
really
you guys I mean it's unranked right you
can name the cards all right we're
talking about fuel generators he wants
me to play it because he thinks you
think you think that one cash is and
more valuable than a hit no way yeah
that is the that is the debate isn't it
uh I think you guys definitely value
heat over cash that's not the way
there's no way that you think I mean
it's it's and also it's not heat right
it's an energy you can use later for
other projects oh yeah but if I can just
play it when I ever need the energy it's
it's one so yeah you convert a cache to
a heat but also you have an energy to
spare for later yeah but the energy you
always have yeah and I mean in the
meantime cash is clearly worth less than
heat really but I mean if if this is the
argument you just wasted three Cash
because you took the card and you do not
really want to play it right now
well you already had energy with tapping
I think literally the only reason not to
play this card ever is because it's
extremely late in the game and that he
doesn't matter or it's going to get
generated
or because you fear tapping what you had
on your hand otherwise it's always good
yeah that's that's definitely where I'm
I'm different because I'm I tend to
Value money a little bit over heat but I
don't know after meeting you guys I
think it's kind of equal I think I'd
value heated
well yeah that might be a good call yeah
I mean just just think about the last
game right where you wanted to end but
you couldn't yeah so if you could
transfer some of the cash you had to
heat to finish
I mean of course last game heat finish
because of the new Zone Etc but it's
still a Tempo issue in there yeah
um
okay do I take sponsors here yes or no
maybe
yeah whatever
and even if you wanted to go ocean
convert and then Greenery I mean ocean
and then convert The Greenery you could
have already played the ocean Dustin and
got an extra cash
oh sorry I was just removing my phone
what did you say
um we we were talking about the SP ocean
on top on the two plants to get the
conversion yes if you want to do this
right now you should have already played
the ocean last gen because it's an extra
cut
yeah
but now I find myself in a situation
where I kind of want to convert but I'm
gonna risk it because the cards I want
to play before I can wear so I'll let
you be the judge if this is a
a bad play or not
but I want to do this and then play uh
an ocean let's see if I can get away
with it or if you're gonna burn my seven
plants right now
Ah that's sad
you cannot
imagine picking up Media Group and then
playing two events before that
huh
sad no
Oh I thought you weren't gonna do it
no
so do you think it's do you still think
it was the correct player do you think I
should have played it safe and just
played ocean and then convert
immediately
I mean you lose
two plants with your ocean
oh which oh yeah you want to play a
space event ocean yes exactly so it was
it was basically I could have played it
safe and had like the the the just an
ocean down now and then the conversion
or I could have chanted like I did and
that would give me plus two plans plus
three heat plus three gold
I mean I think you have
a good
a good reward for the risk you take in
that you get three heat three Cash two
plans if you wait yeah
so I think it's fine and it's like okay
if I have I mean because if if you play
the event and then you convert you still
have like three four plans left probably
so it would really only be giant ice and
demos yeah that really kill you yeah and
yeah it's a little unlucky that I had
of course I am mad that I took Media
Group and couldn't play it
no it's just the sponsor C sponsors is
such a trash card if I didn't keep
sponsors I could have just played Media
Group demos
because I wouldn't need loan yeah and so
I just wasted six cash and one cash
production and loan for that yes I see
it's only due to sponsors C sponsors
trashcan
but it gives you make a credit
collection
think about all the great you can get it
yeah I mean
it really expected you to convert so I
was not thinking about playing demos oh
yeah that's a nice selected sponsors so
because you thought I was going to
convert immediately which was my plan
until I saw these two cards and then I
changed yeah
but I I think this risking this was not
stupid I think
it was not exactly good but you had a
reason for that and so that's fine
hmm
[Music]
I think Highlander yesterday mentioned
that sometimes he would play micro Mills
buy micro Mills and play it and feel
fine about it
and it just it it physically hurt me
when he said it but uh
when you guys are valuing heat
production this highly I can understand
why
micro Mills is interesting if it even
outs evens out your production
because sometimes you're just at seven
heat prod and you have close to none of
it and then micromoves is really good
in in general like for example for me
going from one to two heat prod is not
exactly better than invention contest
yeah
but would it be worth it for me though
is the question
I think I'll do the math for once and
see if I can what I can afford here
so 22
actually sounds like a good idea doing
some math
I can only afford to keep two cuts maybe
three cats
we also have this
yeah I think this looks okay
oh I also got some cashback from uh
listen
hmm
do you know what
I'm gonna I'm gonna play the stupid
micro Mills for the first time in my
life I've actually bought this card now
I can uh I can call myself
a real gamer Temple nerd
yeah welcome to a new world
for sure
okay let's protect my plants before evil
people wanted to say no no I cannot
avenge
laughs
my poor plants
at least I can get a conversion now so
that's also the second time I have
protected hubs yes guaranteed hundred
percent also 100 number today
I guess I need to chill with my trigger
finger
because you have no plants
oh no useless
so you actually have plant removal and I
just trolling me maybe you're just uh
bluffing maybe I am maybe I'm not
think about it Jesus
I kept Nitro Moss over a quiet company
by the way because it was very very
close to being active and you had a good
incentive to place the third ocean
yeah so I think these two plant
production are way more important than
the cash you get from company
[Music]
um
that makes sense
especially because I also have Habs so I
could already have this little like
three to four plant production early and
just stack it till Infinity because you
can't remove it
and also maybe I have insects again
oh
maybe just say maybe
I could also take the water actually
should I take the water hmm I think
considering
I was also thinking about taking the
card and the plant on the on the right
I think in general the ocean is a very
valuable Tyler yeah and especially like
now in your position you are up top with
a Greenery so you can get the rebates
and you also have a Teleport to the
bottom and then it's very good to take
yes
I think I'm done
[Music]
so I can steal the diversifier from you
maybe let's see
because I can get this Tech now
it's like last game if I'm lucky I can
steal the diversifier from you if I'm
not lucky I cannot I I think this is the
second time I even looked at the
milestones
because I think on Hellas it's just
if you're lucky you're lucky and you get
them if not well then maybe not
yeah but I mean I'm in the situation I
need one more attack what can that be
could be I think it's it's especially
fine because it gets you a conversion
next gen and you start next gen yeah so
in this otherwise it's maybe a little
late for designed but I think this
combination of facts makes it okay yeah
except maybe I'm not converting if I'm
stealing your Milestone so I have to
think about that
let's see
[Music]
I mean it's actually quite hard to get
the attacks right
so you should look at my tags and look
at the draft and see if you think I have
the possibility to get it
you're gonna have a microbe some stupid
micro card I don't know
why wouldn't I already have played it
yeah
okay this is
a little interesting
I just can't decide between giant ice
asteroid and AI Central here
all right that's a no-brainer in my book
okay
I would have taken I think
I mean usually the no-brainer is giant
ice asteroid
but yeah
in
if you just combine all the facts that
you already have energy have three tags
have decent production
yes and my plants are protected
giant ice becomes way less good
and so
I think it's probably better to just at
least cut AI but I think it's always
fine to speculate on AI yeah even though
I'm very far ahead with only one tag
yeah so here is uh here is my dilemma I
can either deny you a jovian amplifier
water import from Europa or I can take
Electro catapult which is good for me
and I'm not sure
because you have you have two tags and
your assassin systems so you could be
that you want this Jovian amplifier if a
little you feel that you have it
I mean I think it's always fine to take
it as sudden a relatively independent on
your hand because you can always find
some later and I already have two and I
already have a malt so it's good
um
the question is just is electric cut any
good for me it is not so I would maybe
just cut it from you but I think in your
position
I mean do you have any other place you
want to line up this trend no not other
than converting that's pretty much it
because I think electricad is a very
good developing play
and so
so because it's good for me and then I
let you have the
is that what uh you would prefer I think
it's a tough call to be honest I'm not
sure
what degree it's a tough car
because the I mean denying stuff is
because also I just have two tags right
now and you haven't seen any others and
so the question is is it I mean I will
obviously take it but will it be good
for me
this I'm not 100 sure but I'm 100 sure
that electrocut especially if you have
no other place good for you yeah so I
would probably take electrocut in this
situation yeah I'm thinking I'm leading
it towards that as well exactly I was
thinking the same because I don't really
have anything else so
have to do something but I think it's
not a snapping
let's see
maybe you're gonna
watch this card
yes give me Martian survey okay here's
the interesting part if I want to keep
regulars just for AI
hmm maybe maybe not
I mean it's a really bad science tag
but it's also the micro for diversifier
right
that is true which makes it not
completely horrible
oh man
I'm really I'm really I want to take
Martian survey but you're telling me how
bad it is I don't know about birds
though
I guess we both are playing production
but ah
I guess we'll try for birds
not entirely sure it's correct
I mean Martian survey is horrible for me
but would be fine for me do I take
then a regular
hmm
I think it's okay just
I think if it would give me only AI or
the Milestone I would not take regular
but
if I have a good chance on both I think
it's fine to take this expensive science
tank yeah
yeah that's a good point I'm wondering
if I should have uh kept it from you but
I don't think I could have done it
no no it was the
the electric hat right yeah I would just
I would just cut the electrocut from you
[Music]
because right now I don't have any
um jovians
so which any other jovians and so
what did you say why are you inflicting
yourself the pain of playing on Alice
here
because I wanted to give our engine
lover a good play
uh okay oh nice I think it's interesting
that you took the heat because most
people would miss it
and usually it's way better to take the
four rebate but here was completely
correct yeah because of the extra
temperature and because I have an
asteroid waiting to take that extra
temperature from you I know I'm mad
I thought the same I thought normally I
would take it next to the water but in
this case I want the bonus
huh
okay so you didn't take the Milestone so
I can think you don't have it
but I'm not completely sure
yeah I think it's maybe I've been
bluffing this whole time maybe I picked
up something
I mean the read this this would be a
greedy play right to say ah come on you
won't take the Milestone I just convert
my plants so they are safe and then I
take the Milestone this I would
categorize as a greedy play nice
[Music]
did you really just use a plant for that
are you mad
yeah
bro plus they're gold man
is and insanity
okay please tell me you will use steel
in future turns I mean you have four
plant production right yeah it's useful
[Music]
okay so I think one of the things I
always miss is taking the microbe
so let's see if I remember that
hmm
well
definitely getting better cards than
last game that's for sure
okay this is very interesting
ah you have nine titanium I don't want
to give you this titanium card but I
kind of also want to pick so my choices
are research outposts and space elevator
and herbivores
and also a city but
I'm thinking probably I have to take
space elevator so you don't get it but
I'm not sure
because you have flying titanium I mean
I have no steel production
yeah but still still space elevator is
strong for me yeah
post is good for sure but I think maybe
I have to go for space elevator that's
my feeling
what do you think
I think I I in general if I see an
opponent with so many minerals around I
assume that you're stupid they don't
have dumps and so I should deny them a
very good dump
as I am obviously a very very good
player you should assume that I have
dumps lined up for days and so it's not
as efficient but maybe I'm just bluffing
um
ah I mean because I have a very nice
dump here but it's also a little late
for it
[Music]
it's a tough question
I mean I think in your position I would
always take space elevator
because you have to assume that I'm
pretty stupid
all right
that makes sense
the issue is that two of those cards are
also very very good
research Outpost is a little less good
because you already placed the central
Greenery
um but it's still good yeah I think
and now the uh
the space elevator definitely becomes
bigger because it gives me one titanium
production so I can steal another one
from you
yeah
I mean this is uh especially I mean now
it was just good because you got this
and then you can take this
um but
of course uh
uh this
this is also something I would obviously
not know right and because of that I
didn't take it
um I mean research Outpost is also very
good for me because I have ai which you
don't know
um
yep
so I mean herbivores are also a very
good card but still
um
I am tempted to pick up this uh don't
crater just so I can convert but I think
I'll still go for herbivores
herbivores are very strong
you did not pick up the durian hmm
oh I mean it's very
it's very late right
yeah I'm assuming you kept the other
durian so don't you have two driven
amplifiers maybe you don't
I mean I have them but it's quite late
and I need a dump for my titanium and
maybe I have a better one
I mean it in a vacuum it's a good card
for me right now it's so fine question
is just where other cards better yeah
what did you have it was not research
Outpost right it was this is instead of
herbivore so no what did you have
instead of methane from Titan
I took the small animals and also higher
Traders oh okay
and as I have good use for my steel and
also have Media Group I think it's very
strong
yeah
okay let's just
take a decent ish spot for my conversion
[Music]
steal it from the evil man yeah
make sense
[Music]
hmm
laughs
okay so what is your usual feeling is it
like I played AMC I win now no chance
for this loser
uh let's see
uh you you played AMC What's Mc
no no you played am uh asteroid mining
Consortium oh yeah
so is it do you think this is like a
huge play and like I'm screwed no or is
it just decent it's a it's definitely
correct for me but uh it's not the it's
not the end of the world I don't think I
mean it's it's a very strong card and
especially it's very strong if it's
played early and now it's just good I
mean you get the titanium production you
steal but you also give me one cash
production because I'm certain and so
it's still fine it's obviously the
correct play but I think many people
believe AMC is like a game-winning card
in itself yeah I would agree with this
later in the game it's basically like
two titanium production right so this
isn't the game I just view it as two
attention
and I guess one point which is not
irrelevant but
okay let's take the evil man's cash
oh my gosh
because I needed that cash to do stuff
yeah
and let's also do stuff
it's a bit sad because I deactivate my
Dev center with AI
but what can you do
yeah
I mean I already have one Milestone so
getting tripled is not that easy
and so I'm fine if you get another one
because I mean if I wanted to take the
other one I would need to take some bad
place
which one are you talking about
just any other Milestone oh yeah
yeah I think you had the choice to get
Rim settler I'm guessing but you didn't
yeah yeah
huh I was also thinking about starting
an award because because I have cash to
spare right now but uh I'm I'm thinking
with the when you have card draw and I
don't I don't I don't think I'll feel
comfortable
Awards yeah so so difficult yeah
I don't feel confident in any of the
awards for sure
yeah
I think this is absolutely correct
what is this trash
dude
oh no
oh man
this is
not exactly what I wanted to see
okay real Gamers would just sell two and
play SP energy right to activate the
death Center
right
depends on which card you're selling but
probably not I'm guessing
I mean I add trash cards to sell but
still
you don't pay 11 for a con
you just don't do it
right so
I feel like you're kind of a I would
love to play your game I feel like
you're the greedy guy and you're gonna
win late because you have a
yeah I mean I've three draw right which
is a bit more than I mean you already
you still have good production yeah but
same as last game I don't have card bro
so I'm considering uh I'm considering
strip mine
to get the bump but it's a bit late for
all the production
other than that I think I think if you
don't have huge amount of minerals it's
and you also need cheap energy to
activate it's very very costly just to
get it yeah I would have to I have two
energy production cards I have to play
one of those as well so I'm looking at
like yeah sure but you pay all of this
in cash yeah exactly right no minerals
yeah so for the gold to get strip-minded
maybe a bit excessive
I mean it could be if all your cards are
unplayable right at least it's doing
something
yeah so I'm not saying it's completely
bad just that my ideal scenario to play
strip mine for the bump would be if I
have minerals lined up if not I would
prefer to play it like gen 2. I think
this is a a crucial decision actually
because if I do strip mine
I kind of try to battle you in in
generation 11 or 12. and if I if I take
the standard of Technology instead I try
to end the game before you can get the
head of me and Katra
and I feel like
uh hmm I think if you if you're scared
of my late game then standard attack is
almost always better
yeah so I can end the game earlier I
guess yeah yeah I mean you remember the
11 SP greeneries right last game yeah
that's for sure I I made so many
standard projects last game it's uh oh
look energy nice yeah
can reactivate my Dev Center for less
than 11 cash
farming is obviously amazing for you
yeah for sure
so I suppose I had some very good card
to pick
instead of that
yeah hopefully not the anti-gravity
but I'm thinking what else could it be
maybe another Jurgen amplifier could you
be could you be I'm sure
maybe maybe you see it this time yeah
all right
so um I took the nuclear power and hope
you would give me all processor
so I can
try to to end the game but it's uh I
think the bumper does not end the game
faster
no it'll give me like two or three
sure but I mean just just just calculate
it right
how much you pay for nuke power how much
you pay for the bumper and when you can
activate it and use it and then compare
it to standard attack and SP greeneries
yeah
that's a good I think the bumper is fine
if you get it online early but gen 7 is
not early and you also don't have the
energy to activate it right now so it
would be gen 8.
and that's probably surrender
what are you saying it's bad yeah
yeah that's really bad but if you like
the energy production card I bought in
the beginning you you think I should
keep this as well right
no
it's it's not the beginning anymore
right yeah this is energy production
declines and values the game goes on
because at the beginning you play it you
get heat from it at the end you only get
the energy yeah right an energy play gen
1 is
both valuable as the energy production
to enable cards but it is also embedded
key product too so it's extremely
valuable to get energy down early
all right make sense
so how much would you say energy
production is worth in the beginning of
the game and the later of the game
I think it pretty much never gets below
six or seven
um
but it play gen 1 can be 10.
I think people use these like really
ridiculous heuristics of
stuff from the quantitative guide where
they're saying energies was seven which
is just absurd in the early game
yeah you think what did you say you say
10 and deal again
yeah well I mean like a heat Rod can be
worth less than six in gen one it's
truly with six and
an energy broad play Genuine
is at minimum it's that right
uh minus one
yeah minus one heat but it's yeah it's
heat protection two
um
so you've got six and keep product Value
Plus you have the energy value
uh so yeah I think first generation it's
quite frequently worth ten
It's Worth close to the standard project
all right that's interesting
the funny thing is I I built two
standard energy production projects last
game and I felt really bad about it and
that's eleven
so yeah but it is really bad because you
did it to play Immigrant City
like SP power immigrant city is spending
to reducing your economies yeah you can
possibly do hmm
dispense
69 immigrants today 11 on the power and
then return for this you get negative
one cash production
it sounds like a good deal right this is
terrible yeah I agree
and I mean I know that there's the idea
of ramping up your cash fraud with other
cities in the back of your head but the
issue is that those cities get usually
played
a lot of gems later
and so you have this effect but for only
three to four genes of production yeah
and then everything is worth way less
so it's in that sense not stacking cash
but rather taking some cash and delaying
it
five to six trends
yeah
um I'm with you I I agree
what
putting the ocean there is
probably not a good call
I would love some ocean near my city
yeah
there you go
huh actually I should convert now
yeah
certainly
okay
Milestone is a good point I I remember
this when I uh thought about it earlier
and now I forgot all about it again
I'm probably going to take ram settler
now
nope
[Music]
but to be fair I only had two actions
right so I couldn't have
I'm gonna I could take rimsat life I
just play wife but I think I prefer
another play if you play what
uh what import from Europe okay
I mean but you have a point actually I
just [\h__\h] up yeah I think what I did
is uh by putting it up here now I'm now
I'm actually opening the opportunity for
him to to take the the Milestone at the
start of the Next Generation
so for sure there was a that was a bad
call
um
I think it's fine I mean of course I
will take it now because I have a lot of
plant product with my NRA but you didn't
know that
um
but
yeah I think converting is fine because
you yes you may give me the bump but you
could also lose the greenery and then it
would also be a lot of damage oh yeah
I mean of course
yeah typically
yeah I think with one action I took the
water in but the second action I could
convert so I would need one more action
to actually take the Milestone so
if he wants it it's it's his but uh it I
I still should have probably put it down
here I think you're right
I actually intended to do it but then I
forgot about it
and now he's getting
this
temperature bump is he also getting the
water no
[Music]
ah makes a little difference
yeah
that's quite a lot of plans
right back at you
I am
I could hack you now right
I assume you're joking
I do have hackers in hand because hey I
drew it
I mean I would love cultivator but the
issue is we are actually tired
yeah I'm thinking about some of the
awards as well and it just uh
I think I have a not nothing is fundable
here no exactly because you have you
have more cups
you lead in magnate but I can draw all
those [\h__\h] because
I mean I can't even play hackers right
just for magnet
that's true the hack a dream
oh wow
you get a good cut but I got an even
better one nice
you're getting three bad cards because
I'm getting four bad cats
that's fair that's actually completely
Fair everything considered
I like fair games
I don't even know man do I just take uh
take away this in case he needs energy I
think
I mean I have two energy right and I
have enough draws I think cutting energy
is not yeah I have energy saving
underground detonation worms or
geothermal power so
I mean okay there's only one card in
there right really is it worms you're
thinking about oh geothermal power
wait wait do you have worms yes okay I
didn't hear that uh but I have one
microbe so no geothermal is the only car
yeah okay that was my initial thought
the rest are no cards that's just trash
okay
I'm assuming you mean imported hydrogen
it's a good cut
yes I mean you have uh Arrow breaking
right yeah
so it's and also it's an ocean for your
algae so yeah
amazing
oh but now here's the interesting
question do you want the mouth soon or
do you want the bonus I don't think you
can get both oh
I mean I could take the Milestone if I
just found the nice Jovian so you will
see that okay so you're taking the bonus
and not taking the miles down that's
what happening I'm guessing
interesting
I mean the issue is I didn't find any
and maybe if I found a trash Bond I
would still not take it because this is
also a lot of victory points but it's
for free yeah or the other one I have to
pay some stupid cash the local
herbivores and then pick up and then
pick up the Milestone that'll be so
greedy nah if
I should probably just have a chat open
on my other computer actually
on your mobile phone could also work
yeah I'll do that next time I feel bad I
haven't answered any pizza
yeah they're gonna go right now
[\h__\h] this bonus guy we download all his
videos yeah exactly
uh
so I think
I want to do this
do I want three plants or do I want
three bad animals
or do I want to save the card for my
birds
wait which animal no no you you almost
always take imported for plants
well still if I have boats
but I guess it's really good right now I
mean the question is will the ocean be
available then yeah that's good because
there will be one ocean from the
temperature
and then only two are left so maybe you
lose the ocean and then and right now
you get also the three cashback three
heat three heat is useful right now so
this is almost always a great card
and uh if you really want to use it for
your birds you delay it a lot
okay whoever talked in a robot voice was
not recognizable
maybe anthracite is in Germany again
can hear it from his internet
[Music]
yeah I was thinking about it but the
thing is if I play uh herbivores instead
of converting maybe he's gonna burn but
I guess if he hasn't done it so far
you're already footed seven plants so
what what has he not have been played
yeah I mean the most GI already played
so yeah it's a good point
so the more interesting question should
I have played herbivores before my last
green ring because in the I had the
option of getting herbivores and then
conversion and then I had to wait for
Polar Explorer or was it correct to just
converted I mean Explorer
I think because you are you had the
greens you had the plans to convert
twice so I knew I would lose the
temperature bump
but I mean I also knew I would lose the
Milestones I don't know
hmm I think it was the less greedy AKA
risky play what you did
so you can do with that information
whatever you want I would say if it's a
more safe play to not play yeah I mean
safe is less greedy right yeah
yeah yeah okay so let's just play this
amazing art catapult
oh I pulled out of my ass
you have no idea what to do just draw
some stuff
[Music]
take the two parts
now we can break it out
makes sense
I think if I see so many unprotected
greeneries I should protect
yep that makes sense
I had an idea
of maybe playing standard Tech so I can
grab that City next turn or something
but now that's definitely on and by the
way you can always do this right
next turn standard attack SP City to
open yeah sure but then I couldn't
convert uh but now here is here's my
point about this late Marine SM opening
hand the other guy was it also arthritis
who said that uh I should always
androcyte was Galleon was also talking
okay [\h__\h] I don't know your voices yet
I'm sorry
so if it sounds like a baguette it was
scalion
that's racist
it's always very very fortunate
obviously but what about now I can't use
it we're talking about Lake Baron yes do
it look at your cosplay you literally
the luckiest person alive with oceans
okay
this this card is playable like 70 of
the time
probably by 80 two player and when it's
playable it's a single most efficient so
what's the points in the game it also
can be a lifesaver if you're in if you
have to Pivot into a rush situation so
it's always worth two cash
I would buy it in an engine setup I'm
also super poor it's just such a good
car
it's like skipping GI in your opener
all right
yeah as long as you have people that
value heat heat is often high enough
that you can oh that's probably what it
is isn't it yeah it just doesn't matter
like look this card just I mean and your
side if if just both players want to
raise their cash prod and don't play
Heat cards
no it doesn't matter because there's
there's basically if you look at the
events there's not that many there's
like 13 oceans that can be played One's
Gonna Be Free before you get Mariners
out so every single one of the ocean
carts needs to be played except for two
in order for this card to be worth
nothing this is very rarely the case
and and just like talking about it being
it literally just died and you have the
heat you could have gotten to it this
generation only died because you kept
permafrost most people aren't smart
enough to keep part of the frost
imagine this game plays out differently
right he ends up with like some big card
draw engine and he wants to delay the
game right he's helping you with all
these oceans and the game that's a
situation that's unique to a close game
if you're ahead and he's trying to slow
down the game he's not going to play
these oceans and then like marionettes
it's four points
and truckload rebates
yep uh and helps you into the game it's
so much cheaper than two spoons
I see your point
so right now I have the choice between
converting and probably doing this or I
can start pumping up the heat a little
bit I'm I'm playing to get this last
bonus
so I'm thinking maybe he has one more
water card in hand but he has no crash
so I don't know just just convert next
to myself you're always converting your
plants right so yeah
weather
it's planting Steel
yeah and he means next to my city of
course yes right right
I'm gonna convert the steel into money I
hope you're happy
yes I am very happy that you converts
steel and not the very valuable plant ah
I see
all right
do you know any players
I can't do I think I think trees and one
standard project and then the bonus or
do I take the bonus next year
you can just take it next gen I mean I
can't take it and so trees is always
better well I can do both but I guess I
can I can do both I can do LG instead of
the standard project so that's probably
better yeah yeah yeah
no debate
uh let's just play the insects I always
have in hand
yes each each [\h__\h] game yes it's
impossible to play a game against you
without you having protected habitat and
insects it's just a it is
what can you do
I heard you said that you're going to
play out which makes no sense
all right it's too late three plans
I guess
they're going to lose TR if you do it
this way
she has 16 Plants so if you have to take
the ocean bonus to open he's gonna take
two or two so Four Points again
so you should always take the ocean here
okay so you want me to to take the the
yeah yeah that was the player I
initially thought just to get the the
ocean right now but then we talked about
I can also take that at the beginning of
the next gym yeah but if you take it at
the beginning of the next gen he
converts twice and gets 202.
because you need it
foreign
Arctic but yeah it's
the spot
I think it's the best but
anyway
[Music]
so let's tell these damned Awards to
start some of this [\h__\h]
those rewards are still insanely tight
yeah yeah shopping you have six cards I
have five cards I'm thinking about
magnet but I'm sure cultivator Maybe
I think cultivator is the best one for
you right now yeah
the rest of my cards are pretty much
just
like maybe one playing card if I need
the plans for the last gen maybe maybe
birds make standard Tech
I think magnet is not defensible for you
because I just have so much draw and can
play so many [\h__\h] cards you're right I
think Olivia is the way to go to
overtake you
I think cultivator is probably the only
one I'm getting this game it looks like
to me
but I mean the big question is can you
finish next gen that is the question
yeah
oh yeah so are you saying I shouldn't
spend eight gold right now in case I
need that equal to finish next turn you
should calculate it but probably if you
don't take the award now I can get
another one that I have guaranteed and
then you don't have the victory points
to finish I think it feels like I have
to take one award and then you can have
the other two but it's only heat right I
get one hit for free
and then I need maybe three standard
project heat yeah and you have enough
cash for that I should have yeah I can
also yeah also have standard ticket for
one I think it's uh it's okay like this
let's see
yep
let's see you play versus a very engine
heavy cooperation oh yeah with AI and
you are
and it looks almost like you are winning
or at least you are equal
isn't that interesting
well I think if you're winning the game
you're like ah I'm the boss and if
you're losing the game you're gonna be
like I only lost because I went for for
some engine
sure but how often will I win this game
uh from this position where I am I think
you have you have quite a decent
position here yeah I think you're right
you have of course some more water can
start but I don't know you didn't really
go all that in for so many children so
I'm not so scared about that amplifier
in your hand so what else I think the
methane was the only one I saw
yeah
and colonizer but it was dead already
and also the the one that's still
titanium but then you had some something
else instead of approach yeah and and
you had no Titan yeah
so this time I have to do some math
because I'm I can deny you
anti-gravity but I don't even know if
you can get to five so I mean five texts
right now right yeah if you could get to
Seven Armenia yeah
what's the cost what is the other good
card
um I'm thinking about well enhancers or
the other ones are Heather or SF
Memorial
while enhances I mean I mean it's it's
obviously viral or AGT here yeah
um
I think it's
interesting because both can be very
strong in the right circumstance like
AGT can fall flat if I have no tax
viral can fall flat if I have no other
you didn't
I think
you don't know enough about my hand to
evaluate viral right
no
but because if you if you knew that I
had I don't know birds and maybe some
other stuff and ecozone but I mean I
played it last gen
um but if I didn't play it and you knew
it then viral would be the obvious pick
here but like this I think it's just
a matter of chance like you can imagine
okay how much bio related stuff is out
there
I mean
if you really do have two science texts
then it's then you can draw some cards
sure but it's not that many cards you're
gonna get discounted so it's pretty much
for the three vpa and anti-gravity and I
don't know maybe I mean I I already have
Earth catapult right so I can play
really cheap stuff yeah I think I'll
I'll think uh I think well that's
probably what I should go for
I mean both both are valid for different
reasons yeah but maybe I I think the
argument that this will end here
guaranteed and that I probably also have
to fund an award means that I'm cash
tight enough so that AGT doesn't do much
I mean you already know about loan right
that I already used it
see this this dumps this dump sponsors
if I wouldn't have kept sponsors early I
would have loan now and could play alone
for free with three rebate and then AGT
would really fly
that's I mean loan is gone I don't know
if you know about media archives
um but also I mean I have 10 events you
have five events so media archives is
not bad
but still it needs to be very specific
cards to make AGT worthwhile and I think
probably viral has a higher expected
value here yeah it's also the thing if I
do I think you're gonna convert one
Greenery to help me close or do I have
to standard project that
because then I might not have enough
gold to actually keep some of this
oh here are more science texts either
[Music]
um
pretty much useless at this point
yep
Advance maybe you would want that I'm
not sure it would only because okay you
didn't even want it okay
well the funny thing is now I oh I can't
hmm
I think I think I might call a chance
that I'm taking out anti-gravity anyway
but probably you wouldn't take it if you
haven't taken it the first time
I mean viral would be quite good for me
here so you dodged a bullet
so
I need 26
for standard technology and one standard
Greenery
so that's 26.
then I need 33
plus three
the last one you don't get
so twins
I actually have a hard time closing this
sucks I mean you can obviously take the
rebates in the east
so 26
and 33 that's 59 I think and then plus
three
oh yeah I don't think I keep any
character it's gonna be really close
okay where do you convert first
yeah I think I'm not going to keep by
leaving I think I just have to
I mean what what would profit from viral
in your hand
uh I'm looking at stuff like uh birds
and I can get some but but now that I
look at it I don't even have cash to
play birds and ensure that the game
closes so yeah yeah I don't keep
anything
this is the viral is a page here okay
where where do you convert here
um I'm thinking I'm getting the one plan
to the north east and then I'm getting
the rebates next to the ocean
than one plant and two plants yes
yeah
and then it looks like I'm gonna be one
plant short in the in the extra round
but I think this is a
I also have this uh electrical circuit
one
oh actually I forgot about this I have I
have plenty crash no one
uh-huh
but still maybe you need this cash to
finish right yeah because I mean from my
perspective I don't know your standard
tag so I would look at you and I see
okay you have 55 cash you can generate
another 12. yes so you have 69 67 cash
so what you're saying and you already
see that I can close the game which is
why you're gonna take the last plant
right now yes because now if if you sp
Greenery you have more than 42 left and
so everything is fine yeah so I just
take the central rebate here
uh Central Greenery here
and I think then
I can take a look at the awards and I
see you can't really take one
because if you want to finish you need
to spend all your cash on SPS and
then I can easily overtake you in one
word yeah
I just chill and draw my cards
oh nice mining Expedition great card
thank you game yeah
it's awesome I mean I have Media Group
right
so it's it's not too cash for an O2 and
two plant height yeah it's very nice
very broken
where can I get YouTube
I'm thinking about uh playing standard
technology and then uh
let me see if I have enough cash so I
need 33 still so I can get this for 21.
I mean Aztec is always cash
it's always cash positive right
yeah what is it so Aztec is always good
it's six cash and you get nine back yeah
yeah yeah I'm I'm just debating in my
head whether to take the city uh next to
the water on the top next to my two
plants I just placed
to take that City and still close the
game but it's pretty close
uh
if if you do
6 and 33 right now you have waited you
didn't take your cash yeah exactly oh I
I we have to say we have six yeah we
calculated that you can even finish
without Aztec so I think depending on
the cards you have
you can consider that I think it's
better than the cards I have to be
honest the only thing is the the algae
in my hand I might want that to get plus
one Greenery in the extra round
so there's a lot of math right now
actually
because I mean the question is just if
some of your plants will disappear
because I have animals yeah I mean you
you have Birds right maybe fish is still
available I think that's all yeah
hmm
so if I do it I get
six for standard Tech and then I have
22 for the city minus two
so that's 26 for the
yeah then you have 29 plus 12 so 41 so
minus 33 8 cash left for other stuff
yeah
yeah but it would also be enough for
Birds yeah yeah Birds argue so I think
it's fine to do this play yeah
it would give me like
I don't know I'm denying you a little
bit maybe and also I'm getting
I'll also get one rebate I don't know
it's a it's a tough call I think it will
give me three points to the city and be
annoying to you so I think it's okay
yeah oh the other player would have been
to start magnet and YOLO but I don't
think I had their confidence to do it I
stupid right you are in
in VP up me now you will get another I
don't know maybe five six seven with
greeneries and stuff so I already need
to close a 22 VP Gap right now with the
stuff I have
and then giving me the option with
flipping an easy award is just insanely
stupid
I see what you're saying that's a good
point
oh nice I drew dust series best card
eagle
yeah why this is my standard public city
what
oh
is it because you can
um I can place the city and still close
the game but I'm not sure if it's uh
it's correct
uh we were just talking about this
he has 12 cash left from cat and oh okay
but elevator now loser Greenery which is
the award which is
pretty close for three three points
instead of just playing our cards which
is also three goats it doesn't cost the
city
oh sorry what uh I'm I'm lost I I've I'm
I'm winning call you you just played it
you just played a three a three-point
City yes for a 28 or 23 cash yes 22 cash
20. you could have just played Birds
analogy
which is awesome awesome I think I'll
still get to play one of these I can
play either LG Opitz I think no
really oh wow
no no here he can he has one temperature
and he has 12 cash from Captain 33 and
then I can sell two cards I should have
enough to play LTE at least that's my
plan
what
uh
I think I have eight and then I can sell
two cars so I get back to ten
am I wrong are you playing together or
one against the other or we play against
each other yeah just for uh but we are
talking yeah exactly I'm learning it's
basically what happened he's Temple
nerding me look at this guy yes
that was actually good it's the it's a
part of the game I want to get better at
being Timber notes like you guys
and I mean it's Hellas and we finish in
gen nine come on what's going on that's
uh
um
I took Alice to have a relaxing 12th gen
game
I already feel like a symboner
okay I haven't started calculating what
I want to do but I guess I think you
want to start an award for 14 that seems
good for you know
yeah of course
I'm not sure the one for 20 is is worth
it for you but one for 14 maybe
eccentric or something I mean you can't
take the one right you pay 22 then you
have eight okay so you cannot say you
know take an award and finish
so I don't need to think about it no
right
great I like not thinking
it just sell some stupid [\h__\h]
can't take a contract too heat missing
so sad
uh let's see
yeah I just think the game two of my
cards play algae
[Music]
you have the mod right so you see the VP
I see um 81 and you're 64.
and I'm poor you said
uh
okay just sell this stupid card
play this not so stupid card
look at this viral enhancers getting
three no four extra plans
yeah Advanced ecosystems yeah
oh well enhances what are talking about
didn't I take that
yeah yeah you cut this yes over AGT yes
so in this scenario this was absolutely
correct because I had no way to activate
AGT yeah
but there are scenarios where AGT just
skyrockets me so now I'm at 13 plans
next round so with LG I can get
um 16 exactly and then I have enough to
get one
planned from the map so this means you
must have two animals to deny me this
play I know yeah which don't exist right
it's maximum fish it has to be fish and
then maybe one more or something I'm not
thinking about predator or some [\h__\h] no
yeah so algae is better
yeah I think I'm thinking the same thing
makes sense
obviously a little bad because I have
fish
but not that's which would also be nice
with viral
no but that's what I'm saying even even
if you play Fish I have one yeah yeah so
that's what I said which is good because
I actually did this and you could still
prevent it yeah
okay can I flip cultivator no [\h__\h]
way no that's not happening I think it
was correct starting that one
take fish get some cash
ah yeah I should get an award
Centric hello
and I can still
is very welcome
and now I have this wife in hand that
needs 10 cash so four victory points but
still 10K um I'm bad which one is wife
water import from Europe
that makes sense and I can't do it
but I get one from this Heather
that's it close game
actually I think I think you just won by
one one plant I could get two Greenery
sound and I I went by one point right or
maybe two points yeah I think you win by
one point one point yeah holy hell
close game
see out Temple nerded
yes
I am at the same time I'm happy and at
the same time I'm very disgusted with
myself
that I played like this
what can you do
oh actually I also got herbivores maybe
I went by two points
oh yeah you won by two
okay I'm not one of those anti-social
guys I of course also give other people
victory points
just saying nice nice thank you
I was I was thinking the two water is
technically correct
[Music]
yeah but it's anti-social I raised the
total score and both people feel better
yeah you're right
that makes sense
yeah it's a great game yeah for sure
nice Tempo play I'm pretty good despite
of what you saw the last game the last
game was terrible I feel I'm pretty
strong with the greedy approach but this
Timber approach I definitely still have
a lot to learn
I mean I think last game you just played
it insanely stupid with those SP
allergies I mean though they were just
you were just throwing money out of the
window constantly
and in here there were a lot of quite
efficient and good plays and then in the
end you see that even in a very tight
game you don't need this
big advantage to carry you to generation
14 but you can just win on the spot and
I mean I had no choice I had to push the
parameters because otherwise you get
even more victory points and so the game
just finished in nine and my AI couldn't
really shine and I mean I had Earth
catapult but I only developed it in gen
whatever seven very late and so it also
couldn't really shine I mean it was
still fine but not the PowerHouse that
it can be yeah
and otherwise I think in another gen I
would have just slaughtered you
completely
yeah for sure
so it's it's very close if I if I was
not able to end this gin but then it
comes back to could you have done
something early in the game to to drag
out the game to get one more gin I'm not
sure
I don't think so
because
um I mean I was actually
I think I pushed one heat where I wasn't
sure if I should do it but I mean if we
just think about this gen you place the
city so you had enough cash for another
2sp heat so this would have not changed
anything and I think it's better to just
take the immediate cash production
Victory point and don't give it away yes
at this point so
I don't think though I mean there was
this I mean the one thing I could have
done differently was playing methane but
it was already Gen 6 and I mean I had my
titanium already allocated towards
playing NRA
and so I didn't I didn't want methane
methane would have given me the
Milestone but it's Gen 6 so the
production is worth almost nothing
yeah and I guess one more point in case
you played the wife as you call it but
you ended up so yes I couldn't do it
yeah see it's very late for methane
so this I mean those those cheap Jovian
usually Saturn is very strong on this
map because you just get one milestone
for free
but I couldn't find any cheap Jovi in
this old game I mean like Vesta or
Miranda or something like that yeah
to just give me the Milestone and then
I mean I I already got diversifier a
little bit more expensive but it was
okay because it also gave me AI but I
had no way to get one of the other
Milestones yeah
yeah so in retrospect maybe you had to
start in a one of the War it's focused
on maybe maybe you had to start
eccentric or something before I started
cultivena but it's hard to say I mean
it's it's just a difference of 12 cash
right yeah
again if you think about it if I had to
take this award earlier I also got my
economy a little bit because I delay
other plays which will cost me probably
I don't know like two or three victory
points in the end and in the end this is
your SP City yeah
and then you don't get that but you can
get your award a little bit for a little
bit Market yeah
and so I think overall this
I mean the one of the issues where I got
a lot of ground was the demos early
but I think it was fine from you to play
it risky because you had a lot of reward
to get
and after that I at least I don't really
remember a huge misplace to see so it
was just very fine Tempo gameplay
though did anyone buy something
interesting in the chat I'm assuming
they are yeah I see far
question marks